oh my god she's so insane her she's
insane she's Emily Dickinson Emily
Dickinson is not only an incredible
writer but just a fascinating person oh
yeah I'm a real catch the interesting
thing I would say about this show is
that we're retailing the story of Emily
Dickinson in a way that's fresh and cool
and a little bit dangerous I'm in love
with death he takes me out for a
carriage ride every night he's such a
gentleman
you are such a weirdo if she was a
normal girl this would be a normal
coming-of-age female story but she's
Emily so it's just not what you expect
why can't I go to the college I wrote
about it in my essay I'm a proper place
of women you can start really kind of
leaning into how ridiculous the time
period is in some ways and how
ridiculous it is that it feels relevant
today in a lot of ways this story has an
astonishing amount of parallels to our
21st century everything my generation
can watch this show and feel like the
hundreds don't feel so far away are you
thinking what I'm thinking yeah boys are
stupid that's what's been so fun is just
playing the reality of what it feels
like it would be to us today we're
always in a bit of a metaphoric history
space Elena took Himalayas work and made
her a modern woman that we could all
relate to today
kissing my god what is wrong with you
her whole reasoning is for playing human
beings that just existed in a different
time doesn't mean they didn't have fun
we need to throw one of our classic
Dickinson house parties there's a dance
sequence watching everybody going from
like a traditional line dance into a
twerk is the most crazy things will be
part of I think young people today maybe
don't have the same need to put
themselves in boxes and a kind of
redefinition that Emily would really
approve of I have one purpose on this
earth and that is to become a great
writer
you